good morning john so a weird thing about
modern life is that i can certainly
forget what happened to me two weeks ago
but google never will
so because i can let's go back through
my top
22 most recent questions that i asked
google
starting with the where's so i was
actually curious about where world war
ii soldiers pooped when they were in
cities like did people let them in their
homes or did they go to the cinema or
something or just poop in the gutter
what do they do but i found no
information about that i just found a
lot of pictures of dudes pooping in
trenches which was
looked awful looked very bad the
nitrogen and the atmosphere came from
geological processes in the earth
and then it's pretty heavy and stable so
it sticks around for a really long time
that's why there's so much of it and the
lunar landers tend to be really
interesting the landers they would
launch and then they would take back off
and reconnect with the command module
and then be jettisoned
and almost all of them were crashed into
the moon
to do seismic experiments except for
apollo 13 which was used as a lifeboat
and then they crashed it into earth's
atmosphere and apollo 10 the mission
before the one that landed on the moon
the ones just flew around the moon they
actually jettisoned that lunar module
and it went into solar orbit
so it is currently out there we could go
get it
it's just in space now for some what
this first one is just me trying to
figure out why
when where and what can be answered with
then there and that
which just it can't be a coincidence and
i'm getting closer
to the answer to this question i'm not
quite there yet a pine cone
turns out to just be a pine cone i
thought maybe it was analogous to some
other structure
it's really not it is a conifer cone is
a conifer cone that's what it is it's an
organ of a plant but interestingly
physiologically those little
uh pollen things on conifers are
actually pine cones
is physiology something you can apply to
plants i don't know if that's just an
animal thing i can google it okay i
typed in is and i didn't think about
using is
the first one was is a puzzle a story
which is a wonderful question
and i don't remember asking it and also
is aphid honeydew edible
but yeah plant physiology is definitely
a thing uh and now it's the 25 most
recent questions i asked to google
the oil lamps that romans used were the
ones that sort of look like genie lamps
except they were made out of clay and
there'd be a wick in there and it would
wick the oil up and you could light that
on fire and the oil they used
was olive oil meat more what's protons
taste like sour cicadas eat tree sap but
not the sticky kind you're probably
imagining the really liquid fluid kind
that's just the water that travels up to
the leaves and what is college
like i don't know but i think we should
be asking the question who
we only got one who who recorded the
first noise and you might think that
that was thomas edison
it kinda was technically the first audio
recording was not replayable
it was the pressure wave of noise being
transferred into a waveform
edouard leon scott de martinville
i don't do french developed a device
that could turn sound into an
image and actually very recently for the
first time we were able to turn that
waveform back into an audio file
and here it is
i do not like that wise honestly i am
still completely dumbfounded by all
three of these
hows always asking questions about the
structure of the online media ecosystem
phone gyroscopes continue to baffle me
and yes we are now at the point where i
have no idea how long we have been
in this current situation oh there's
this catherine thinks that
googling things about animal crossing
taints the experience so i have to sort
of be quietly googling and be like well
let's try this and finally
just because i guess there needs to be
an end to this video john i would like
to present to you
a poem when did luke perry die when
dove's cry
when would the moon crash into the earth
john i'll see you on tuesday wait
another question has appeared
how much money has the awesome socks
club raised well john google doesn't
know the answer to that question but i
do
over 600 000 and remarkably that is just
a side effect of this dang amazing
service that will send you
a pair of socks designed by a different
independent artist every single month
they are lovely
high quality socks that i wear now
almost exclusively and right now
subscriptions are open but only for a
limited time at awesomestocks.club